the thing that matters the most for
YouTube is how much are people watching
the video and watch time is the case so
if you say big David Goggins on the
thumbnail and then you even put in your
coming up is a little clip of like you
talk about Goggins but then it's a 40
minute video and you only talk about
debuggings for like two minutes of it
you will probably get destroyed on your
watch time because people aren't
watching if you just go for
click-through rate you could just say
I'm giving everyone a million dollars
for free get a huge click-through rate
but they're not going to watch the video
because you're talking about something
completely different